und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten guten abend
in den flutgebieten von rheinland pfalz
und nordrhein westfalen hat eine weitere
woche im kampf gegen die katastrophe
begonnen und das was sie angerichtet hat
der blick zum himmel bleibt sorgenvoll
auch andernorts wo heute wieder stark
regen fällt wenn das zutrauen dass es
hierzulande so schlimm schon nicht
kommen wird ist dahin
in berlin begann heute die politische
aufarbeitung der frage wie konnte das
passieren
solche zerstörungen so viele tote und
was lernt man daraus
der innenausschuss des bundestages tagt
trotz sommerpause klaus brodbeck
berichtet es gibt viel zu erklären von
einer tragödie wird der innenminister
sprechen darüber dass die zusammenarbeit
auf allen ebenen besser werden müsse und
dass die länder unverändert bei
katastrophen zuständig bleiben sollen
weil die das so wollen
wenn man will kann man berge versetzen
glauben sie wirklich die zuständigkeiten
der länder eine schweigeminute für die
opfer der flut und gut drei stunden
voller fragen und erklärungsversuche
später mit klar
die aufarbeitung der katastrophe wird
dauern
auch im parlament man erfährt nämlich
dass trotz über 170 toten niemand etwas
falsch gemacht hat
das ist natürlich im vorwahlkampf zeiten
vielleicht verständlich es war eine
sitzung in der mit ausnahme einer
fraktion der afd
alle anderen fraktionen vor allem
versucht haben zu schauen was können wir
in zukunft besser machen
in der kritik warum systeme die zwei
alarmierten habe wohl nicht ausreichend
gerade bei der warnung der bevölkerung
hat es offensichtlich eine ganze reihe
von pannen gegeben missverständnissen
wie auch immer
deswegen ist es notwendig dass der
innenminister auf die länder und auch
auf die kommunen zu geht mit den ländern
gemeinsam und den kommunen gemeinsam ein
system aufbaut längst in arbeit seit
vergangenen herbst und damit lange
vor der flut sagt seehofer auch wenn
mein name system
wir werden die waren app brauchen wir
werden das die sms brauchen wir werden
die serien brauchen wir werden rundfunk
und fernsehen brauchen mehr befugnisse
für den bund bei großen katastrophen
fordern die grünen
wir hatten nico unna pandemie wo klar
geworden ist dass bund und länder
stärker zusammenarbeiten müssen wir
hatten fluten auch schon in vergangenen
jahren und daher ist das herzstück
unseres vorschlags die zentralstelle
beim bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz zu
schaffen
dabei wird das bundesamt bereits seit
monaten umfassend reformiert überfällig
seit jahrzehnten nicht früh genug die
ersten schritte sind eingeleitet
es ist dramatisch und es schmerzt dass
uns diese krise zuvorgekommen ist
katastrophenschützer im dauerstress ein
minister kurz vor der rente
sie werden es brauchen können in diesen
tagen wie so viele für die menschen an
der aa ist
berlin heute ziemlich weit weg es muss
weiter gearbeitet werden
aber auch auf kommunaler ebene beginnt
die aufarbeitung von fehlern und
versäumnissen wer ist schuld die frage
ist auf keiner ebene einfach zu
beantworten
schauen wir ins hochwassergebiet an der
ahr auch im weinort dernau wurden die
menschen vom ausmaß der katastrophe
überrascht flüchteten sich auf dächer
oder bäume der ort ist schwer getroffen
und die erinnerung an die nacht als das
wasser kam schmerzt susanne gelhard
marvin manns ist sanitäter beim dlrg und
seit tagen in dernau an der ahr
unterwegs als er vom hochwasser hörte
hat er sofort reagiert ich war um an der
küste ich hatte wasserrettungsdienst und
bin extra aus der ostsee jetzt herunter
gekommen meine ganze familie wohnt hier
das wasser wütete mit unfassbarer
zerstörung überspülte fast das ganze
dorf
noch immer können sie hier nicht
begreifen was in der nacht vom 14
auf den 15 juli genau geschah so schnell
mit dem wasser innerhalb einer halben
stunde war hier alles voll
und wenn wir nicht die umliegenden
bauern hätten verwehren wir ganz ganz
schlecht strand
die landwirte waren als erste da und
packten mit an
ich will doch keinen kein irgendwas
vorwerfen oder so was ich weiß nicht ob
die feuerwehren hier unten sind sie
total selber abgesoffen und konnten dann
selber wahrscheinlich nicht viel machen
und da das fehlte halt da durch
vernünftige kritischer gesagt hat so
leute hier von davon da nach danach
danach das innerhalb von 30 minuten
stieg das wasser um mehr als zwei meter
doch die messsysteme fielen aus der
pegel soll wobei fünf meter 25 ungefähr
soll da stehen geblieben sein
und dann hatten wir einfach selber auch
keinerlei vorwarnung mehr selber für uns
als wir dann erkannt haben was was jetzt
hier passiert ist es auch für uns nur
darum gegangen und selbst so hätten die
fahrzeuge zu retten am donnerstag ab
zwei uhr nachts ging das wasser langsam
zurück und gab ein völlig verwüstet es
dort frei marvin man es wird oft zu
menschen gerufen die das nicht
verkraften können wut und verzweiflung
sind groß wenn wir eine vorwarnung
gehabt hätte die gesagt hätte wären auch
kann unter wasser kommen hätten die
leute hier haben gut teilweise nach oben
gehen die dachgeschoss gebracht keiner
hat mit einem hochwasser gerechnet
kann man die ersten rettungskräfte habe
es war alles ein heilloses durcheinander
keiner wusste wo was ist und man wird
bei hat auch keine informationen
gekriegt
kaum vorwarnung kaum koordination sowie
in dernau haben dass viele menschen im
hochwassergebiet von rheinland pfalz
erlebt der zuständige minister will
jetzt maßnahmen ergreifen
ich glaube wir müssen den gesamten
katastrophenschutz in seinen
organisations abläufen in der frage wo
stationieren wir welches gerät wie
warnen und alarmieren wie es hieß sind
die alarm- und einsatzpläne all die
dinge müssen aus der erfahrung dieser
riesen katastrophe noch einmal alle auf
dem prüfstand in dernau sind sie jetzt
alarmiert an der ahr die so schön sein
kann und so gefährlich nah und susanne
geld ist noch mal zu uns gekommen wir
wollen die situation jetzt so zwölf tage
danach mal vertiefen als landes
korrespondentin susanne sind sie seit
dem 15
juli jeden tag im katastrophengebiet
viele stunden unterwegs gewesen
wie ist ihr eindruck funktioniert jetzt
die hilfe besser wir haben gerade noch
mal gehört am anfang ging das nicht
voran ist das chaos jetzt ein bisschen
im griff die hilfe ist ein bisschen
besser koordiniert jetzt wird
großflächig geräumt das ist ganz wichtig
für die dörfer damit man dort auch
weiter arbeiten kann
seit gestern sind die straßen gesperrt
für große transporte freigemacht
das macht eine menge aus gleichzeitig
können aber die vielen freiwilligen
helfer nicht mehr so spontan anreisen
sie sollten ja ursprünglich in shuttle
fuhren gebracht werden das hat gestern
nicht so gut geklappt heute aber ist es
wohl besser und die gemeinden die orte
die städte dort sind ganz kräftig auf
diese freiwilligen angewiesen
klar ist es gibt nicht die eine antwort
auf die frage wer ist schuld an
versäumnissen das ist multi casa ich
glaube das ist klar sie haben ja jetzt
mit so vielen menschen gesprochen trauen
sie sich so was zu wie ein gesamtbild
also wo gab es warnungen wo gab es gar
keine warnung wurde nahm jungen
vielleicht auch in den wind geschlagen
ergibt sich daraus schon im bild für sie
aber das muss man sehr differenziert
sehen beispielsweise in der eifel haben
die sirenen geheult
bei ahrweiler er nicht bei altena ist
der pegel abgerissen das heißt man hat
gar nicht gemerkt wie schnell das wasser
steigt zudem sind die handyverbindung
dann schnell gekappt worden
der digitale funk hat nicht funktioniert
das ist je nach kommune je nach stadt
unterschiedlich gewesen
es wird lange dauern bis man das alles
im einzelnen ergründet und die ursachen
ergründet aber dass dazu muss man sich
eben die zeit nehmen weil die
unterschiedlichkeit so groß ist also das
steht nach wie vor am anfang aber all
diese punkte sind natürlich ansatz um
etwas zu verbessern dazu gehört auch die
koordination des ganzen einsatzes
nun haben wir gerade den innenministern
rheinland pfalz gehört der auch nach wie
vor aufklärung verspricht und
verbesserung verspricht anfänglich sagte
er wir müssen jetzt erst mal aufräumen
kommt er denn voran mit der aufklärung
jetzt und mit konsequenzen daraus also
wir haben heute ja noch mal mit ihm
gesprochen
zögerlich mann er ist sehr zurückhaltend
wenn es um schlussfolgerungen geht alle
betroffenen politiker sprechen allgemein
von einem tsunami von einem
ausnahmezustand
aber dann wird auch eben sehr viel von
der einen ebene auf die andere geschoben
vom land auf den landkreis auf die
kommunen und was ich sehr auffällt ich
finde es schuldzuweisungen gibt es kaum
denn man es sich doch sehr bewusst wir
leben in wahlkampfzeiten dass angesichts
der vielen toten und verbinden
vermissten ist sehr pietätlos wäre das
jetzt zu missbrauch neuer zu gebrauchen
für parteiengezänk das zumindest hat
sich die politik offensichtlich
vorgenommen
dankeschöns seine gilde hat sie
berechnen weiter für uns auch in diesem
gebiet so für die betroffenen in den
flutgebieten können sie weiter spenden
für das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
für das wir hier im zdf um spenden
bitten sind inzwischen knapp 47
millionen euro zusammengekommen die iban
lautet de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf hochwasser weitere
informationen finden sie unter spenden
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 8 190
und beispiele wie dieses geld konkret
vor
eingesetzt wird zeigen wir später in
unserem heute journal
update die flutkatastrophe hat uns ein
problem vor augen geführt dass auch in
der korona krise schon augenfällig wurde
deutschland hat gewaltige
organisationsdefizite wir erinnern uns
der fehlende impfstoff chaos bei der
terminvergabe ist dauerte ist die
impfzentren mal liefen irgendwann liefen
sie vor allem machten haus und fachärzte
im frühsommer richtig tempo beim impfen
inzwischen aber wird jeden tag weniger
geübte am 9 juni bei der höhepunkt der
impfkampagne danach geht die kurve
bergab der anteil der vollständig
geimpften liegt derzeit bei knapp 50
prozent
für wie viel freiheit das reicht wenn
nach und nach die infektionszahlen
ansteigen die diskussion läuft die
sinkenden impfbereitschaft hat zudem
einen nebeneffekt sind sibylle bassler
schildert impfstoff muss vernichtet
werden andreas küttel ist sauer
der allgemeinmediziner aus hof hat den
kühlschrank voll mit rund 650 5000 astra
zenica ende juli verfallen sie mir tut
jeder einzelne dosis williams ort würden
weltweit ein riesiger bedarf impfstoff
im wert von rund 2000 euro so paetzel
den keiner mehr haben wolle
durch die verunsicherung vor allem durch
die stiko auch durch die politik lag
diese impfstoff wie tot im kühlschrank
und dadurch haben natürlich auch die
meldung zeitigen auch nicht mehr mit us
pass sondern mit bayern tee und da war
gleich kann den impfstoff eigentlich
wegschmeißen
dabei geht es andere möglichkeiten so
der medizin und recht von reizen stein
ist bereits zweimal geimpft aufgrund der
delta variante würde er gerne seinen
schutz mit einer dritten impfung
auffrischen
seitens der stiko die noch daten
auswertet ab wann eine auffrischung
nötig ist dabei würde von reizen steinau
kastration kann das impfzentrum
pfaffenhofen auch hier lagert im stoff
der nicht mehr benötigt wird jetzt wird
er abgeholt in eine sammelstelle
gebracht
es ist total von astrazeneca des bald
verfällt und keiner haben will
gähnende leere im wortes alt die
impfwilligen bleiben aus nur aufklärung
und mobile teams könnten die impfung
vorantreiben so der ärztliche leiter des
infozentrums rundherum wollen wir jetzt
mehr mit mobilen teams dann in die
peripherie gehen sonst haben wir planen
nehmen wir jetzt eigentlich so im
regelmäßigen turnus in turnhallen mit
mobilen teams impfen dass wir einfach
die bevölkerung sondern gemeinsam mit
dem landratsamt haben sie auch versucht
überschüssigen impfstoff dahin zu
bringen wo er dringend gebraucht wird
über kontakte nach namibia
doch das bundesgesundheitsministerium
erteilt eine absage denn sowohl die eu
als auch der bund sind vertraglich
gegenüber den herstellern gebunden
jede abgabe an impfstoff ein anderer
länder an drittländer bedarf der
zustimmung der hersteller das letzte
wort hat offenbar der hersteller jetzt
will der bayerische gesundheitsminister
eine schnelle lösung
wir sind mit dem bund in gesprächen der
bundeswehr eigentümer des impfstoffs und
wir wollen natürlich dass keine dose
verworfen wird und wenn wir den
impfstoff hier nicht mehr brauchen dann
in dorthin zu bringen wo er gebraucht
wird
die zeit drängt bis ende oktober laufen
allein in bayern über 230.000 impfdosen
astra zenica ab
die nachrichten führen uns jetzt ins
ausland gundula gause bleiben aber noch
kurz bei corona reisen aus europa in die
usa werden weiterhin nur mit
ausnahmegenehmigung möglich sein
die usa wollen die pandemie bedingten
einreisebeschränkungen vorerst nicht
aufheben wegen der delta variante und
steigender fallzahlen vor allem unter
ungeimpften heißt es aus dem weißen haus
bundeskanzlerin merkel und die deutsche
wirtschaft hatten in washington auf eine
lockerung der reisebeschränkungen
gedrängt in tunesien spitzt sich die
politische krise zu präsident hat den
regierungschef abgesetzt und das
parlament in eine zwangspause geschickt
offenbar unter dem druck der straße das
nordafrikanische land leidet an schweren
wirtschaftlichen problemen die sich
durch die pandemie verschärfen
vor allem junge leute gehen auf die
straßen und fordern neuwahlen soldaten
umstellten das parlament und verwehrten
abgeordneten den zutritt president said
rief am abend eine sofortige nächtliche
ausgangssperre aus und wies zugleich
vorwürfe zurück es handele sich um einen
putschversuch kritiker sprechen aber von
einem staatsstreich
der weltklimarat hat abschlussberatungen
zu einem ersten teil des neuen
sachstandsberichts aufgenommen
regierungsvertreter aus fast 200 ländern
diskutieren über empfehlungen der
wissenschaft zur globalen klimapolitik
grundlage für den bevorstehenden un
klimagipfel in glasgow zum virtuellen
auftakt verwies die un klima beauftragte
espinosa
angesichts der jüngsten
extremwetterereignisse auf die
dringlichkeit des handelns laut dem
vorsitzenden des gremiums li sei im
kommenden bericht eine bessere zuordnung
von extremwetter zum klimawandel zu
erwarten
auf sardinien kämpfen einsatzkräfte
weiterhin gegen heftige waldbrände im
westen der insel in der provinz oristano
sind
neben löschflugzeugen rund 7500 helfer
im einsatz
die brände waren am wochenende
ausgebrochen mehr als 1000 menschen
mussten ihre häuser verlassen
durch die anhaltende dürre in der region
und starke winde breiteten sich die
flammen rasend schnell aus die
katastrophenschutz behörde warnt
weiterhin vor extrem großer gefahren
wir schauen in diesen wochen regelmäßig
nach afghanistan nach dem abzug der
internationalen truppen sind dort die
taliban auf dem vormarsch in einer
beeindruckenden dokumentation hatte
unsere reporterin katrin eigendorf das
vergangene woche dokumentiert gut auf
die situation vorbereitet rücken die
radikalislamischen taliban vor und
sollen inzwischen 160 der 400 bezirke
des landes unter ihre kontrolle gebracht
haben
das war absehbar und absehbar war auch
und ist auch dass die menschen
zehntausende afghanistan nun verlassen
wollen nur weg so schnell wie möglich
die türkei ist dabei für viele ein ziel
von dort jörg brase gedränge vor dem
passamt in der afghanischen hauptstadt
sie wollen neue reisepässe und dann
nichts wie weg weg aus kabul aus
afghanistan
sie trauen der eigenen regierung den
eigenen truppen nicht und schon gar
nicht den taliban
wir machen uns große sorgen dass die
taliban an die macht zurückkehren
könnten
deshalb wollen wir weg bevor die
situation immer schlimmer wird
die busse gehen von kabul nach neben
ross an die iranische grenze
die erste station auf dem weg richtung
westen es gibt ja so viele probleme wer
bilder in afghanistan bleiben
ich plane nach belgien zu gehen das
nächste ziel auf diesem weg ist die
türkei wieder haben es einige junge
afghanische männer geschafft über die
iranisch türkische grenze viele wollen
erstmal hier bleiben haben kein geld für
die weiterfahrt richtung europa
wir sind zu fuß hierher gekommen jetzt
wollen wir weiter nach istanbul um einen
job zu finden in afghanistan sind die
taliban
die werden schon nach und suchen es
drohe ein neuer exodus warnen experten
hunderte afghanen kommen tag für tag in
der türkei an
das flüchtlings abkommen mit der eu
müsse neu verhandelt und um afghanische
flüchtlinge erweitert werden meint der
migrationsexperte murat erdogan
doch das allein werde nicht reichen das
land ist in diesem rahmen ist wenn die
türkei und auch eu mit ihrer nicht gut
beziehungen hat und eine neue vielleicht
abkommen macht dann wird dieser stelle
weiter kommt und die türkei kann nicht
alleine diese welle stoppen
erste stimmen aus europa fordern bereits
dem türkischen präsidenten noch mehr
geld zu zahlen nachdem syrischen auch
afghanische flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
die türkische opposition kritisiert
schon jetzt einen möglichen deal auf dem
rücken der bevölkerung
die türkei soll für euch die
flüchtlingswelle stoppen mit noch mal
drei bis fünf milliarden euro
bestechungsgeld kommt mal wieder zur
besinnung die türkei ist nicht das
flüchtlings kette europas und wird es
auch nie sein
das thema birgt sozialen sprengstoff und
alle wissen dass hat die aufnahme von
fast vier millionen syrern in der türkei
bisher gut funktioniert könnte sich die
stimmung drehen wenn nun auch afghanen
offiziell dazu kommen die sollen doch
alle bleiben wo sie sind ich will nicht
dass sie herkommen wir selbst fühlen uns
inzwischen wie flüchtlinge im eigenen
land wir leben in der türkei inzwischen
wie fremde egal wurde hinschaut überall
0 syrer und afghanen die türkei baut
derweil eine mauer an der grenze zu
ihrer an eine mauer die die
verzweifelten kaum aufhalten wird
und noch einmal nachrichten und wir
gehen zunächst zur börse kunde dann ja
eines der wirtschaftsthemen zum auftakt
der neuen woche war das heute bestätigte
vorläufige aus für die geplante mega
fusion der beiden größten deutschen
wohnungs konzerne wo novia und deutsche
wohnen das scheitern überraschte viele
stefanie berit es wäre ein
milliardengeschäft gewesen
wie geht es nun weiter er eignet sich
eigentlich rechnen analysten und
aktionäre schon jetzt fest mit einem
dritten anlauf für eine mega hochzeit
der beiden wohnungskonzern denn
gescheitert ist die fusion nicht am
widerstand von unternehmen und
aktionären die beiden
vorstandsvorsitzenden hätten den neuen
konzern sogar gemeinsam geleitet auch
die kartellwächter hatten bereits grünes
licht gegeben
gescheitert ist der deal an den tücken
des finanzmarkt denn ein paar hedgefonds
hatten im vorfeld schlicht auf ein
höheres aktienangebot gewettet vor es
ist die bisher größte übernahme am
deutschen wohnungsmarkt aber vom tisch
wo nokia aktien in den vergangenen
wochen kräftig gestiegen zählten heute
zu den verlierern im dax mit einem
abschlag von zweieinhalb prozent
deutsche wohnen anteile gewannen gut ein
prozent dazu bei einem erfolg der 18
milliarden euro schweren übernahme wäre
wo wir mit einem bestand von 550.000
einheiten zum größten europäischen
konzern für mietwohnungen aufgestiegen
beide konzerne erhofften sich durch
gemeinsame verwaltung ihrer wohnungen
und gemeinsamem einkauf bei
modernisierungen gut 100 millionen euro
pro jahr einzusparen
verbraucherschützer und mieterverbände
reagierten erleichtert auf das scheitern
der fusion sie erwarten von mega
wohnungs konzernen keine vorteile für
mieter für diese bleibt so oder so
vorerst alles beim alten
für diese einordnung einer der
bekanntesten kirchen journalisten der
jesuiten pater bernd hagenkord ist im
alter von 52 jahren gestorben
erst am freitag hatte er wegen einer
krebserkrankung sein amt als geistlicher
begleiter des synodalen weges aufgegeben
der reformdebatte und der katholischen
kirche werde
sein scharfer verstand fehlen so
würdigte ihn die deutsche
bischofskonferenz als vatikanexperte
habe er eine unverzichtbare brücke in
die säkulare welt geschlagen
auch im zdf bis 2017 hatte bernd
hagenkord die deutschsprachige redaktion
von radio vatikan geleitet auch heute
warnte der deutsche wetterdienst vor
schweren gewittern in sachsen kam ein 67
jähriger beim auspumpen eines kellers
durch einen stromschlag ums leben
und in bayern starb bei heftigem regen
ein 57-jähriger der jäger war auf seinem
hochsitz als dieser von einer windel zu
boden gerissen wurde
die region um eglfing in oberbayern war
besonders stark betroffen
teilweise fiel dort bis zu einem halben
meter hagel
einige straßen waren wegen umgestürzter
bäume blockiert
und nun berlin im mai dieses jahres gab
das bezirksamt berlin mitte bekannt die
mohrenstraße traditions- adresse und u
bahn stationen im bezirk wird umbenannt
die rot-rot-grüne mehrheit begründete
das unter anderem mit dem zitat
rassistischen kern des namens der nach
heutigem demokratieverständnis belastend
sei und dem ansehen berlins schade so
kann man das sehen und viele kritiker
vieler initiativen begrüßten die
entscheidung
die hauptstadt mit ihrem neuen humboldt
forum arbeitet gerade deutsche
kolonialgeschichte auf und hat auch
grund dazu
auch zu sprachliche sensibilität aber
muss deshalb die emsstraße wie sie
mancher nur noch
nennen wollte wirklich umbenannt werden
der entschluss war längst nicht das ende
nun eskaliert der streit um sein
zustandekommen und die kaliber werden
größer christhard läpple die berliner
mohrenstraße mitten in der hauptstadt
900 meter lang fast 320 jahre alt eine
traditionsreiche straße mit
gendarmenmarkt der studentenbude von
karl marx spitzen am moor der
nordkoreanischen botschaft und einem ort
an dem weltgeschichte geschrieben wurde
in der mohrenstraße 37 verkündete günter
schabowski den untergang der ddr nach
dem berliner straßengesetz av der
nennung ziffer 2 c absatz 3 wird nun
unverzüglich aus der mohrenstraße die
anton wilhelm amo straße und es benannt
nach dem ersten schwarzen deutschen
rechtsgelehrten und philosophen
jahrelang hatten antikolonialen
aktivistengruppen die umbenennung
gefordert der name mohrenstraße sei
diskriminierend und rassistisch eine rot
rot grüne mehrheit in berlin-mitte
taufte die straße um
anhörungen oder bürgerentscheid
fehlanzeige
dieses bezirksamt operiert lieber
liberal statistisch unter rot rot grüner
führung das muss man einfach sagen
autoritär ohne mit den leuten zu reden
und ohne vernünftige argumente die
mohrenstraße heißt seit 1777 auf leib
und kammern [ __ ] am preußischen hof
vor allem kinder aus afrika waren
verschleppt worden
sie galten als exotische statussymbole
erfuhren eine gute bildung der
historische name gehöre zur
stadtgeschichte sagen 1134 bürger sie
erheben widerspruch gegen die
umbenennung und erleben eine
überraschung
ihr protest stößt auf formale und
juristische hürden der widerspruch ist
gebührenpflichtig und kann bis zu 700 41
eur 37 kosten
dass man dafür blechen muss dass man
widerspruch einlegt eigentlich hinein
gelacht und dachte kann doch jetzt nicht
ernst gemeint sein
ja so eine häme und so eine verarsche es
jetzt wirklich mal falsche ist einer
demokratie einfach überhaupt gar nicht
würdig auffällig keiner der interviewten
will seinen namen und mittlerweile haben
über 700 menschen ihren widerspruch
zurück gezogen
das dient der einschüchterung zum
beispiel sind die anwohner hier in der
mohrenstraße niemals gefragt worden ob
sie es ist niemals mit sie sei nie zu
diskussionen eingeladen worden wir
machen das was das gesetz von uns
fordert was unserer anwohnerin bürger in
von uns gefordert haben und sorgen damit
dafür dass gedenkkultur weiter voran und
weitergedacht wird am ersten oktober
sollen alle schilder ausgetauscht werden
doch das kann bei dieser hauptstadt
brüssel noch dauern denn der streit wird
sicher auch noch vor gericht gehen
es geht weiter das war es von uns und
nazan götte mir meldet sich um
mitternacht mit unserem heute-journal
update wir sehen uns morgen wieder
[Musik]
schon genannt und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter ja neues tief kündigt sich an
und das ist derzeit noch über den
britischen inseln und zieht allmählich
auf uns zu wird dann morgen am
nachmittag und in den abendstunden im
westen für unwetter sorgen
teils mit starkregen und hagel und auch
im süden dass es dann verbunden mit
gewittern im osten deutschlands sind wir
außen vor und in der nacht während die
gewitter im osten allmählich nachlassen
oder auch im südosten im nordwesten
deutschlands richtung nordsee
da regnet es ansonsten lockert es auf
und dort wo die schauer sich verziehen
bildet sich nebel
die temperaturen sinken auf 12 grad an
den alpen am mildesten bleibt es im
nordosten bei 18 grad morgen kündigen
sich dann ab den vormittagsstunden im
westen erste schauer an
und die ziehen allmählich weiter genauso
im norden ansonsten gibt es viele wolken
in den westlichen landesteilen im osten
dagegen viel sonnenschein zum nachmittag
ändert sich das ganze schauer und
gewitter kommen weiter ins landesinnere
voran
und die sind dann heftig vorher am
nachmittag und am abend dann teils
unwetter und das auch im süden des
verbunden mit gewittern
ansonsten weiterhin sonnenschein und
harmlose bewölkung im osten temperaturen
dazu dort bis 29 grad
ansonsten im westen und 20 grad ja unter
mittwoch noch einmal unwetter vor allem
im norden deutschlands und im süden
temperaturen bis 27 grad oder am
donnerstag beruhigt es sich gewitter
dann nur noch punktuell und am freitag
vor allem im süden damit ein schöner
abend